المتهم والذي اسمه فيصل بطه قام الشرطه
شرطه اقليم
مقاطع من التحقيقات التي قال فيها طبعا
بانه ليس مدعوما من احد ولا ينتمي لاي
جماعه على الاطلاق وهو منذ اسبوع تقريبا
انطلاقا بمسيرته كان يخطط لقتل عمران خان
وفقط عمران خان لا لا احد سواه
وعندما سئل عن السبب الذي دفعه لتصفيه
عمران تنقل بان عمران خان ايه يعني يخدع
الشارع الباكستاني بشعاراته
ومصطلاحاته وكلماته الامر الذي لم يعجبني
على الاطلاق وا اردت ان اخلص الشارع او
الشعب الباكستاني من شخص اسمه عمران خان
وقد وصفه طبعا باوصاف عديده هذا المقطع
الذي تم تسريحه حقيقه من التحقيقات الشرطه
مع هذا المتهم اضافه الى هذا هناك طبعا في
كافه المدن الباكستانيه وكافه الاقاليم
الباكستانيه خرج متظاهرون
ومظاهرات حاشده قاموا باغلاق بعض الشوارع
الرئيسيه واحراق الاطارات المطاطيه وكذلك
اطلاق شعارات وهتافات اننا جميعا دون
عمران خان وعمران خان همم احمر وما الى
ذلك من هذه الشعراء